allons-y
donc supposons que nous frappions le corps avec une
énorme lumière ultraviolette ou
simplement très puissante et je pense que vous avez
dit que cela n'a pas été vérifié mais vous
allez le tester et ensuite j'ai dit en supposant que
vous apportiez la lumière à l'intérieur du corps
vous  pouvez ce que vous pouvez faire à travers
la peau ou d'une autre manière et
je pense que vous avez dit que vous alliez tester cela
aussi
semble intéressant, puis je vois
le désinfectant où il l'assomme
en une minute
une minute et est-il possible que nous  peut faire
quelque chose comme ça
par injection à l'intérieur ou presque un nettoyage
parce que vous voyez que ça pénètre dans les poumons et
ça fait énormément de temps donc ce
serait intéressant de vérifier ça mais ça
me semble intéressant donc
on verra mais  tout le concept de la
lumière, la façon dont elle la tue en une
minute, c'est assez puissant, a
fait un travail vraiment formidable, donc je ne
pense pas que vous deviez être honnête, mais nous en
reparlerons dans les années à venir